so Lori Lightfoot is out as mayor of
Chicago we celebrated on the show
several weeks ago and she lost in the
primary but unfortunately in her place
Chicago voters have selected a candidate
who appears to be worse Brandon Johnson
is his name he's an open racist like the
mayor he's replacing he supports
defunding the police in one of the most
dangerous cities on the continent now
we're learning that Brandon Johnson is
also opposed to educating children here
he was in 2018 explaining that what he
taught students he didn't like giving
homework were bad grades
what it taught me though was
pushing like to eliminate sort of the
standardization of our Public Schools my
students sometimes would get frustrated
I didn't offer any test prep many of my
other colleagues were doing it at the
time I was pushing our Administration to
move away from that
to be quite Frank with you I didn't
issue a lot of homework for students
that was my own way of sort of rebelling
against the structure
um
I don't think I ever gave a kid an F
I just I don't I don't know how a
student sits in front of you and fails I
know some professors may find that you
know you know it's a slightly troubling
so by not teaching the students he was
quote rebelling against the system they
actually tried this in South Africa and
you know what they got
illiteracy and then a failed State Dan
proft is a radio host in the city of
Chicago He joins us tonight Dan our
apologies on behalf of the rest of the
country that you're a great truly great
city has been taken over by someone who
seems even crazier than Lori Lightfoot
is that right
well it is right uh you know what you
have going on in Chicago is slow motion
civilizational suicide and that clip
from Brandon Johnson speaks to it you
had a historian Victor Davis Hanson on
your program last week and he said the
nation is going through a revolution
right now and they don't even know it
Chicago the corollary Chicago is going
through a funeral right now and we don't
even know it right now in the city fewer
than a quarter of Chicago public school
students can read or do math at grade
level that's according to state test
scores and yet that's the response from
your incoming mayor his that's his
vision for Education K-12 education this
is somebody who touts himself as an
educator he's a representative of the
Chicago Teachers Union which Lords over
education in the city civilizational
suicide you don't teach children how to
read and write you excuse the criminal
element among young people Major Crimes
are up 46 percent year over year in
Chicago and Brandon Johnson's response
as you you mentioned and as he touted
during the campaign is to send social
workers and EMTs out to respond to 9-1-1
calls that involve the possibility of
violence this is somebody who is openly
antagonistic toward police he has touted
defund police as a laudable political
goal and you have a city that has
decided to throw in with him Brandon
Johnson his base of support 29 of the 50
Awards he won those are the awards where
High where crime is the highest so where
people are suffering the most from
endemic violent crime
that's who Carrie Brandon Johnson to
Victory I I don't know a better
commentary on what the situation is in
Chicago than that
well he appealed to race hate and that's
what got him elected he appealed to race
hate as openly as any Southern Democrat
in the 1950s so that's just true well
but appreciate it but so go ahead yeah
well I just want to say one thing that
is important and you talk about this on
your program a lot it was a racially
based election but you know who really
put Brandon Johnson over the top was
leftist rich white women and so of
course of course course that's the axis
right there Dan Prof you know it works
on Happy private Equity wives yeah met
them great to see you tonight thank you
thanks Tucker
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight